us is set to cement a Jordan peel as one
of the best modern-day horror directors
due to the unease and undertones set by
his latest creation at the tethered
those who've seen us and know that it's
one of the most unnerving horror films
of the last decade and that is partly
due to the bill Ness characters that
stalk the Wilsons throughout this video
I'll be breaking down everything that
you need to know about the tethered as
well as the meaning behind them this is
full spoilers ahead so if you don't want
to know anything about us then I highly
suggest that you turn off now without
the way I'm definition and welcome to
the channel where I explain it so you
don't have to ok so first I'll break
down the plot of us to give some context
to the mysterious doppelgangers I won't
be spoiling the ending of the film or
anything so don't worry about that
anyway us is set in present-day and it
follows the wilson's who are returning
to the mother of the family Adelaide's
childhood home for a summer getaway
Adelaide has a lot of unresolved trauma
from her childhood and at the vacation
spot she slowly reminded of things that
happened to her due to some eerie
coincidences
this creates paranoia in her mind that
something bad is going to happen to her
and her family and after a tense day at
the beach Adelaide and the rest of the
family return home only to be confronted
by a group of doppelgangers so who
exactly are these well at Jordan peel
when speaking frankly about the
creatures stay at the following we're
our own worst enemy and that idea
created this monster the tethered I
wanted to forge this new mythology that
explored our duality and the duality of
the characters I think what was a fun
challenge for the actors was finding the
connections between the characters and
their counterparts so from that we can
assume that perhaps the tethered are
birth through sub consciousness and
trauma that manifests in the film to
torture the protagonists as the premiere
for the film when questioned the
director said on the broader strokes of
things this movie is about this country
I was stricken with the fact that we are
in a time where we fear the other where
it's the mysterious invader that we
think is going to come and kill us take
our jobs or the faction that we don't
live near that bow in a different way
than us we're all about pointing the
finger and I wanted to suggest that
maybe the monster we really need to look
at has our face
maybe the evil is us this makes sense a
lot and though this may be a reach
perhaps the title of US isn't just us
but it's actually also us as in the
United States if correct this could also
mean that perhaps we must look at
ourselves to be positive in order to
create a better world for tomorrow no
this isn't an anti America hey Ron it's
just that perhaps the film is putting
the responsibility on us for letting the
world get to the point that it is the
scissors to hold their own significance
to peel which conforms to the overall
message of the film peel also stated
when we talk about the scissors and the
rabbits for every choice like that there
are several different reasons that click
to me but the first test that anything
passed was the genre test so does it
conjure the horror genre to me which is
a limitation that I feel very dedicated
to working within I think rabbit and
scissors
they're both scary things to me and both
inane things so I love subverting and
bringing out the scariness and things
you wouldn't necessarily associate with
that this again cements that wilds
ghosts werewolves and more maybe scary
on a supernatural level in real life
when compared to the mundane they are a
mere fantasy
however everyday life can be subverted
in several ways to show just how
terrifying our world can be if used with
the wrong agenda this is the true
meaning of the tethered they are us or
rather what we would be if we gave in to
our deepest and darkest fears and
desires and ended up casting out the
good within in order to carry out
actions that would have a negative
effect overall it's a brilliant unique
and enthralling message for a horror
film that showcases just how brilliant
that peel is in creating alternate
realities it's no wonder that similar to
get out us is receiving high praise and
it's certainly one of the smartest
Horrors in
decade obviously I'd love to hear your
thoughts on the tethered and if you have
any theories and gods to them do you
agree with me or do you take something
else from them comment below and let me
know and if you enjoyed this video then
please like it and make sure you check
out my breakdown of this week's big
Netflix release triple frontier which
will be linked at the end this is the
channel for people who were mad into
movies so if that's the kind of thing
you like hit subscribe thanks again for
taking the time to watch this
I've been definition you've been the
best I'll see you next time
take care peace
[Music]